I'm joined today by Jason Payne who's
the founder and CEO of Aida diamonds
which is a custom fine jeweler that
works exclusively with lab-grown
diamonds Jason diamonds are a topic I've
been interested in for a very very long
time I am hostile to the diamond
industry in many ways for what I see as
an immoral marketing decision to
increase the market price of diamonds
connected to very very few families
around the world as you know and I am
eagerly waiting for something to
dislodge what I see as the artificially
high price of diamonds I would love for
you to tell me that your lab-grown
diamonds are going to be that thing
although I know that it's actually not
not quite so simple so maybe let's start
a little more broadly why lab-grown
diamonds to begin with so what's
misunderstood about the laboratory-grown
diamond industry is that the entire
purpose the industry is not to make what
you think of as diamonds it's not to
make gemstones out of diamonds it's to
make high-end technological applications
of diamond so that's everything from
surgical knives to water purification
tools to semiconductors and even quantum
computers and so what I'll argue is that
an investment or a purchase of a piece
of jewelry with laboratory-grown
diamonds is directly funding the
research and development of all these
fascinating applications of functional
diamonds that will help people around
the world for decades to come
so is that is is that kind of how the
diamond industry is bifurcated which is
gemstone diamonds and then all other
diamonds for sort of like non jewelry
applications correct okay now if you
Raul if you're relying decades or
centuries all of those diamonds were
coming out of the earth and there were
industrial quality diamonds and there
were gemstone quality diamonds so the
industrial ones were the small brownish
diamonds that were used for cutting
tools during World War Two and beyond
and today there's really
three categories of diamond there's the
industrial diamond
there's the functional diamonds and
there's the gemstone diamonds how do you
grow a diamond in a lab it's one of the
most arduous and difficult processes
that humanity has ever harnessed and it
takes an immense amount of pressure and
heat and an incredibly high degree of
precision to pressure-cook carbon into
diamond so the best way that I can
describe it is that we are taking
graphite and heating it to about 1,500
degrees Celsius and turn it into liquid
carbon and pressurizing that carbon to
over a million psi or 70,000 atmospheres
worth of pressure and at that high of
temperature as we cool it down from
liquid back to a solid form the solid
form is my favorite form of carbon a
diamond basically were ya know creating
McCann I was gonna say merely were
recreating conditions underneath the
earth where carbon becomes diamonds so
to the layperson if you were to see a
gem a natural gemstone diamond that
would be used in jewelry and one of your
lab grown diamonds whose purpose would
be an industrial application for example
would the layperson notice a difference
between the two a a layperson would not
frankly nor would a gemologist so with
all of the standard tools that a
gemologist uses there's no way to
decipher the difference between a
diamonds whose origin is underneath the
earth and a diamonds whose origin is
above the earth why they're both a
diamond they're both crystals of carbon
so one of the things we do with our
clientele is that we've got two diamonds
of very similar quality ones the
laboratory-grown diamond and one is a
mined diamonds and we show the clients
the two diamonds without telling them
which is mine and which is
laboratory-grown and the clients cannot
tell the difference between the two that
is fascinating that is fascinating
now I'd love to maybe get your
now understanding a few sort of more
general elements about this industry and
this is this is like I said something of
significant personal curiosity you go
and you buy a gem diamond natural
diamond and it might cost five thousand
dollars for example yes you immediately
go to the store next door and you say
you would like to sell that diamond and
of course as exists in any business that
has overhead and is trading in the
buying and selling of something you will
be offered only a fraction of that five
thousand dollars and then immediately
the diamond you bought for five thousand
and maybe let go for twenty five hundred
will be sold by the new buyer for forty
five hundred dollars or maybe even the
full five thousand is there any
explanation for that other than that
this is a very concerted effort to deal
in incomplete information with the
public or in other words are there any
actual economic reasons other than this
we have to make up for our overhead why
the value of one particular diamond
would fluctuate sold so wildly within
transactions there is an economic reason
and the reason for that is that diamond
is a complete outlier compared to any
other economic good in the sense that it
has the exact same utility today as it
does 50 years from now
so a refrigerator a car radio that was
purchased 50 years ago has little to no
utility today correct whereas a diamond
there's really no way to tell if it was
mined a century ago or ten days ago and
so it's an interesting phenomenon that
the generations of diamonds that have
been sold the success of the diamond is
forever campaign after world war two
those diamonds are now being
reintroduced to the supply in a
significant quantity and that is having
a dramatic effect on the price of
diamonds but really to answer your
question directly is that diamond is
such an outlier in that it's forever and
so it has the same utility forever
regardless of when it was mined or grown
how is that different and I
ask not rhetorically nor sarcastically
but how is that different from for
example sapphire so it is not different
from other gemstones but it is different
from other consumer products so what I
just said about diamonds I think you
could apply to most gemstones out there
and then how about gold what about gold
because gold although gold is gold and
and sort of some of that same logic
would apply Gold can take different
forms you can have gold as a backing for
paper currency or not and there's sort
of some variations how might we
conceptually think about the difference
between Dimond and gold yeah so gold is
a fungible asset in the sense that you
can melt it down you can repurpose it
you can blend it with other metals like
we do for making fine jewelry you can
purify it to a hundred percent pure gold
to make Boyan diamonds are interesting
and that each individual gemstone is an
individual SKU they have specific
characteristics that are different stone
to stone and so there's a reason that
gold has been a financial I'll say
financial instrument but a unit of
Finance for many decades to centuries
whereas diamond really has never been
viewed or utilized in that way something
that we focus on is using recycled gold
recycled platinum in the jewelry that we
create we pay a premium for metals that
are refined here in the United States
because of all the sort of negative
environmental consequences or
externalities that can be present in
mining of fresh or new gold let's talk a
little bit about that right so with
regard to diamonds there's this term
conflict diamonds conflict-free diamonds
it seems to me again as a layperson that
one of the great benefits of a lab-grown
diamond if not that it is going to be
less expensive which you've already
pointed out that that that's not really
the selling point of the lab-grown
diamond right is that you can
definitively know that no little kid
might have
drowned or whatever it is that that
could happen having obtained a
particular diamond you can say that
definitively and from the research that
I've done even some of the diamonds that
are sort of marketed as conflict-free by
retailers they don't really know that
that they're basically going on somebody
else's say-so is that not a major
opportunity of the lab-grown diamond
which I which I know you know you talk
about industrial applications rather
than gemstones is that not a big
opportunity uh I think that that I think
it's a wonderful feature of
laboratory-grown diamonds that I as a
retailer can tell you not only where the
diamond was grown but quite literally
who is the technician or the PhD who is
running the diamond press that actually
grew that stone right um so I think
that's that transparency and that
ability to get all the way back as far
as possible in the supply chain is a
huge selling point or feature of
laboratory-grown diamonds um I do want
to clarify the Kimberley process is now
well known by many of your viewers or
readers but that the Kimberley process
is limited to one small aspect of the
supply chain of diamonds and that's
ensuring that there are no civil wars or
civil conflicts or insurgents that are
funded by those diamonds so today as it
stands the Kimberley plot process does
not cover other aspects of potential
human suffering or misery in the supply
chain of diamonds it's only focused on
insurgency civil war and conflict so in
other words if I understand correctly
even a diamond if correctly labeled as
conflict-free tells you nothing about
whether there are little kids involved
in the mining or the working conditions
it's merely a sort of evaluation of the
political circumstances around the diet
of the mining yes that's correct
that being said there are multiple
efforts ongoing today to bring
blockchain technology to diamond mining
and to scan the diamonds as far upstream
as possible and then have the pedigree
of the diamonds tracked all the way
through cutting and basically going from
the mine to
market for ore mines diamonds and that's
something that I fully support and
applaud and hope that that is a
successful utilization of blockchain to
ensure that there are no a conflict or
problematic diamonds that end up in the
supply chain going forward so we as
humans are getting increasingly close to
being able to harness the natural
resources from celestial bodies and I
don't mean planets but asteroids for
example what happens and I would love
for you to tell me the truth about this
because I'm so curious about it and I
have no reason to doubt that you will is
the diamond industry scared of the day
where we find an asteroid that has more
diamonds on it than the entire supply of
diamonds on earth first let me talk
about the existence of what I'll call
super terrestrial diamonds yes without a
doubt there are asteroids as well as
planets in our solar system that likely
have iceberg sized diamonds floating and
seas of carbon on those celestial bodies
I love it so there are NASA scientists
that believe Neptune and Uranus may have
very large size diamonds present on the
surface of the planet so first off I do
think that is a very real possibility
and I do believe that the mining of
asteroids is something that will be
important for the continued growth of
the human race frankly I think the
bigger concern for the diamond mining
industry is diamonds running out on the
serta near the surface of the earth
versus a celestial body being a new
source of diamonds and what I mean by
that is that since the untick WA T the
human race has pulled about 6 billion
carats of diamonds out of the earth and
I've pulled the public filings of the
largest diamond mining companies in the
world there's about one point four
billion carats of diamonds in reserve
and similar to Peak Oil we're well past
peak diamond and it's really a matter of
20 50 years before the known resources
of diamonds on the surface of the earth
are depleted and it's no longer viable
to extract diamonds out of the earth so
what happens then I guess is the
question barring being able to harness
these extraterrestrial diamonds for lack
of a better term does that drive the
cost of diamonds up even further when
it's basically you've got to buy a
diamond from someone else because
there's no new diamonds being found I
think in the short to medium term it's
actually to have the opposite effect and
that prices of diamonds are going to
fall and the reason for that is we have
to go all the way back to World War two
so during World War two there's a huge
need for diamond grit for industrial war
efforts both the Axis powers and the
Allies really focused on finding and
sourcing diamonds for their efforts it
was a key part of the industrial
revolution that happened around World
War two so in the years immediately past
World War two you saw a four-fold
increase in diamond mining and that grew
significantly in the decades to follow
and so what's happened is it's really
baby boomers are the first generation of
time where the majority of Brides
received a diamond for an engagement
ring and so for the first time really in
humanity the generational passing of
diamonds in a large capacity is starting
to happen and that will mean hundreds of
millions of diamonds of used diamonds
will be coming back on the market in the
decades ahead and that may even in some
years outstrip the supply that comes out
of the earth and if that's to be the
case big increase in supply not a huge
increase in demand will see the price of
diamonds fall in my opinion absolutely
fascinating Jason Payne is the founder
and CEO of aided diamonds they work
exclusively with lab
diamonds Jason I really appreciate you
talking to me it's a pleasure